welcome to the civilian playing rocco
motion locomotion play them yes once
before with the wind so let's hope we
make a small small serious out of that
kale can play a sixth chabanenko
angeleyes don't foresee five you know
what a play tonight bd7 when I was still
playing this regularly in tournament
chess i still play it from time to time
it's not like i have discarded the
opening but it's not I don't play it all
the time like I did it at some point I
was really a busy playing that he's
played some right age five and now this
III or Bishop t2 yeah this looks good we
had this Bishop g5 and back to a four
but there is some some methods behind
that it's um about weakening my Kings
side of it the some yeah III intends to
play Bishop f4 anyway can i play me five
here
Oh is the Sun is there some drawback the
h5 night is really a bit loose em but ok
if I've what's the idea of all of that
okay well this this cannot be the
refutation really here not that is bad
but it's not proving that i did
something terribly wrong ok um II for to
send him back or is there drawback to
that
yeah if I would just drop drop back to
g1 and I'm not sure that my pieces are
well placed for coming we should reform
I'll do something else now g6 and Bishop
g7 try to use the bishop on the long
diagonal ok so the bishop on g7 has a
useful role and age 6 this is no
weakness whatsoever this looks nice he's
now correcting as Bishop placement he
played Bishop e2 i'm quite sure i will
hit me attacked age 5 night but it i
thought was pretty clear that the bishop
is wrong money too let's see here can i
play I could play Knight to c4 yeah it's
a one good news
would be nice to get this Bishop Bishop
see one is obviously having some
drawbacks I'm a five probably this be
five okay this is useful anyway
controlling before so that possibility
for a move by white is not so dangerous
anymore how to continue here I can try
to get the night over to e5 and maybe h5
h4 is also an idea the main point of
Nigeria is that eva is answered by
Bishop takes d4 so we cannot play you
form maybe baby Bishop takes d5 as a
means that you can play takes Knight
takes and ce4 hangs to find the Queen
eggs and this was maybe possible
maybe okay you should I try to reroute
I'm trying to reroute you Queen to h5
and this also I believe night x f2 and
the air 9f to king of 293 looks pretty
strong so it needs to address that I
think yeah and he did address it the
question is however still here on this
night f form I mean age 39 moves night
f4 that's a bit a bit uncomfortable
95 mile FY that's really really not good
time warning yeah yeah I know it's not
get into any hectic here got one minute
left oh well one minute that's really a
bit much orbit a bit too little I mean
but ok the position is perfectly ok I
can I can play with this Queen age 5
idea I've got 93 Black is in good shape
but all the time Queen h5 is still I'm a
very very interesting move to consider
next
maybe a f4 f4 can be tricky f 493 I can
play a five-night see one is good for
black no it is not good for black ok so
f4 I actually need to go hmm i should
add two are taking it is not good maybe
I've fire possible I can go back to the
70 maybe that's even the right move f
497 at five yeah this is not really a
problem the question is where do you go
with ok I am I must move obviously he am
III is very weak and I get the night to
have six like Knight f6 94 enter and age
5 is an additional IDM
yeah yeah this time is a new ring new
ring mine because it's now tricky to
even check maintain the playable
position also a 585 it takes c5 acer is
hanging now it's falling apart here
really also 92 in DM here we go and at
the end there is there's problems all
over the place I can take Jack take a
one check take it three so I want an
exchange and I'm up on the clock
sometimes it works out this this gamble
trading a time for good position but
it's not working all the time of this
name check check white resigned yeah
your position I mean really my time
management is somewhat crazy I know okay
but the position was really good at this
point I mean here this is just very nice
this is this position the i think
justice we need to check this spot here
i thought this is missing this capture
here on is the smooth
okay well I didn't calculate any of that
but i think i would have played it this
leads to a good position now with 95
because it's white squares light squares
are so weak something like the jack
intending here and whatnot d8 here from
here okay i didn't do that he played
rock g1 and now I i really get get
something going here Dungey 500k it's a
matter of time really I needed to play
now yeah okay well a computer gives the
catch as the best move okay I couldn't
really I needed to play instantly this
is interesting if I work here it once it
was to check here okay yeah that's that
strong but okay it wasn't in my wasn't
possible for me to do when T intending
to to get the night over to f6 down
still ya know a five is already very
good I when I went here Jay okay no way
five and white falls apart now by the
time I had to come up on the clock
considerably check until I swear to be
easy to play yeah so what went wrong I
mean white spent quite some time here
with Bishop e2 and so on and i don't
really i think it i am not sure but
maybe around here he needs to do
something else i don't i'm not i don't
really know it too well this line but i
don't think that that's that before can
be the the real the real problem for
black
yeah i'm not sure why but should be to
really because while the night on h 5
we'll return to f6 in any case and the
bishop is just misplaced on e2 now why
can you can argue that yeah maybe it is
not misplaced actually if you think
about it it's it's okay well gee 3
implies in a way that you will feel
cheto but he had actually controls the
importancy foursquare so in it i cannot
easily enter with my night which I was
able to do in the game maybe yeah maybe
that's a real point was very tricky but
where we actually did learn so much time
like on every move right okay well
thanks for watching